[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días un
programa semanal en el que analizamos la
actualidad más destacada del continente
africano comenzamos con los titulares
la situación de los migrantes de origen
africano en túneles es alarmante después
de enfrentamientos con la población
local en la ciudad portuaria de sfax
cientos de ellos han sido deportados de
manera forzosa a zonas desérticas en las
fronteras con Argelia y Libia sin acceso
a alimentos ni agua en la región de
chile al norte de Etiopía se ha generado
una preocupante situación tras dos años
de conflicto armado hoy existe un
elevado riesgo de hambruna que amenaza a
la población una situación que se ha
visto agravada por un escándalo
relacionado con la malversación de la
ayuda humanitaria
y para finalizar nos trasladamos a
Londres donde se está llevando a cabo
una destacada exposición que pone de
relieve la fotografía como herramienta
para explorar la historia del continente
africano y construir nuevos relatos
comenzamos nuestro recorrido de la
actualidad africana en túneles donde la
situación de los migrantes de origen
africano es motivo de Gran preocupación
en los últimos días se reportó un
incidente en la ciudad portuaria de sfax
la segunda en importancia en el país y
principal Punto de partida de la
migración irregular hacia Europa solo
está a 150 kilómetros de la costa
italiana allí un ciudadano tunecino
presuntamente fue apuñalado por tres
migrantes este incidente ha
desencadenado una ola de odio y
violencia que ha venido gestándose desde
hace meses por parte de la población
local según testimonios recopilados por
periodistas alrededor de 1200 migrantes
incluyendo mujeres y niños fueron
expulsados por las fuerzas de seguridad
hacia las fronteras con Libia y Argelia
donde se encuentran abandonados en medio
del desierto sin acceso
alimentos ni agua es importante destacar
que la situación ya difícil de los
migrantes de origen africano en túneles
se ha grabado aún más tras los
comentarios extremadamente violentos que
el presidente tunecino
realizó contra ellos En febrero para
comprender lo que está pasando allí
hemos entrevistado a
periodista y activista político tunecino
quien nos brindó detalles sobre la
situación de los migrantes expulsados
por las autoridades tunecinas
lo que sabemos al menos por el contacto
directo con los migrantes sobre el
terreno es que no tienen agua ese es uno
de los grandes problemas recientemente
hemos sabido que las autoridades libias
han enviado algunas botellas de agua
pero llevan varios días sin agua tienen
muy poca comida y muchos de ellos están
heridos porque han sido golpeados por la
gente de fax y también por las
autoridades así que están en condiciones
bastante difíciles
y obviamente todo esto ha sucedido sin
que haya habido ninguna comunicación
oficial del gobierno en la que hubiesen
reconocido su política de deportación lo
que dificulta aún más el trabajo de las
ong y de las personas que quisieran
ayudar a los migrantes porque
oficialmente nunca ha habido ninguna
comunicación que permitiera acceder a
las zonas donde han puesto a los
migrantes
estos migrantes se encuentran atrapados
en las fronteras de tres países
túnez Libia y Argelia que rechazan
brindarles ayuda y acogida a menos
explicó Cómo se ha llegado a esta
situación marcada por la creciente
xenofobia y racismo en Tunes
no tiene sentido decir que hubo un
momento preciso en el que comenzó el
racismo en túnez el racismo siempre ha
existido en túnez Por otra parte si hubo
un momento en el que el racismo se hizo
institucional Por así decirlo fue el
pasado mes de febrero cuando el
presidente de la república publicó una
declaración en las redes sociales en la
que acusaba a los migrantes los cito de
alterar la demografía de túnez
acusándolos de formar parte de un
complot occidental para cambiar la
demografía de túnez para despojarla de
su identidad árabe musulmana lo que
ocurre actualmente en fax es en realidad
consecuencia lógica de lo que venimos
oyendo desde hace varios meses sobre los
migrantes lo que venimos oyendo por
parte de las autoridades pero también
por parte de ciertos partidos que antes
no existían que no tenían legitimidad
política y que ahora son cada vez más
fuertes pensamos en particular en la
existencia de un partido nacionalista
tunecino que retoma las teorías del Gran
reemplazo que retoma las teorías de la
extrema derecha Europea y que acusa a
los migrantes de ser todos criminales
con esta lógica de extrema derecha que
conocemos y que pide el cierre total de
las fronteras tunecinas y este repliegue
identitario
y antes la situación que podría
describirse como Trágica resulta notable
el silencio tanto de las organizaciones
nacionales como internacionales
[Música]
creo que hay una verdadera falta de
voluntad política para luchar contra lo
que está haciendo el gobierno creo que
hay muy pocas organizaciones que tengan
la voluntad de decir lo que está pasando
he hablado con especialistas que me han
dicho que podemos utilizar el término
crimen contra la humanidad porque
estamos atacando a un grupo que
intentamos destruir
atacando
e intentamos quitarle a túnez toda su
identidad africana de hecho y por eso es
chocante que estas instituciones no
reaccionen pero no creo que tengan la
voluntad política de hacerlo
según analistas políticos existe una
preocupante tendencia hacia una
radicalización del pensamiento y las
actitudes de cierta parte de la sociedad
tunecina así como unas creciente
hostilidad hacia los migrantes y a las
personas negras muchos observadores
temen ahora que se repitan escenas
similares a las presenciadas la semana
pasada en un contexto de indiferencia
generalizada
cambiamos de tema y de país a finales de
junio un equipo de periodistas de la
agencia de noticias
visitó tigre por primera vez en dos años
después del alto del fuego acordado en
noviembre que puso fin a los combates
entre las fuerzas regionales y el
ejército Federal etíope las armas han
dejado de sonar pero la ayuda
alimentaria fue interrumpida debido a
casos de corrupción les alertamos que
las siguientes imágenes pueden herir
algunas sensibilidades
en esta cama de hospital sigue lucha por
respirar y por aferrarse a la vida con
10 años Ahora solo pesa 10 kilos su
familia desplazada de la región de tigre
tras dos años de guerra se encuentra en
una situación desesperada
o ya no puede comer al principio
intentamos darle sopa mezclada con leche
Pero por desgracia ha dejado de comer
todo Porque para empezar no teníamos
comida en este hospital de la capital
regional ya ocho niños han muerto de
inanición en mayo
este pediatra elige algunas de sus
palabras en inglés para no ser entendido
por su joven paciente y sus padres
esta familia ha sido desplazada no
pueden comprar los medicamentos que
necesitan para el tratamiento y nosotros
no podemos proporcionarlos Así que los
tenemos en observación hasta el final es
terrible
desplazamientos de poblaciones
destrucción de cosechas interrupción de
la ayuda alimentaria en tigre el
conflicto entre las fuerzas regionales y
el ejército Federal está provocando una
grave crisis alimentaria agravada por la
sequía tras el alto el fuego del pasado
2 de noviembre los brujos de ayuda se
han reanudado Pero los dos principales
donantes usaid y el programa mundial de
alimentos descubrieron un desvío
generalizado y sistémico de grandes
cantidades de alimentos que
interrumpieron sus programas el gobierno
etíope criticó la decisión y declaró que
iba a abrir una investigación los
agentes humanitarios que están
identificando a los futuros
beneficiarios de la ayuda esperan poder
redistribuirla rápidamente Seguimos
avanzando hacia la reanudación de las
distribuciones de alimentos en Etiopía
esperamos reanudar las distribuciones de
alimentos en julio Empezando por la
región del tigre según las autoridades
regionales de tigre al menos 595
personas
han muerto ya de hambre desde abril pero
la cifra podría ser mucho mayor por su
parte el programa mundial de alimentos
estima que más del 80% de los 6 millones
de habitantes de tigre dependen de la
ayuda alimentaria
concluimos nuestra edición desde la
ciudad de Londres donde se lleva a cabo
una exposición de fotografía
contemporánea el evento tiene como
objetivo desafiar la mirada tradicional
hacia el continente africano y construir
nuevos relatos a través del poder de
esta forma de arte la exhibición
denominada un mundo en común se expone
en el renombrado tate Modern de Londres
más de 150 obras de 36 artistas
africanos están presentes y cada artista
aporta su propia perspectiva sobre
África y su relación con la historia y
el resto del mundo la curaduría está a
cargo de ocey aquí en nuestra
corresponsal en Londres Luisa Pulido
tuvo la oportunidad de entrevistar en
esta exposición puedes encontrar muchas
formas diferentes en las que los
artistas se involucran con la fotografía
a veces es un retrato a veces es a
través de la investigación de archivos a
veces es fotografía urbana fotografía de
paisajes creo que están conectados con
esta idea de una especie de humanidad
colectiva o una humanidad compartida que
vincula a África con el resto del mundo
por lo que es realmente un intento de no
solo pensar en el tipo de fotografía de
una manera tradicional ya sea artística
o documental pero las formas en que el
artista desafía las fricciones entre las
formas tradicionales de representar la
historia africana nuestro corresponsal
habló también
presentó una instalación titulada
historia de una ciudad en caja su
trabajo aborda la influencia de los
colonizadores en la dirección y
administración de la ciudad de lagos la
artista nos compartió la historia de su
obra
historia de una ciudad en una caja es mi
interpretación de lagos habla de
información la información es poder la
información puede ser accesible y no
accesible este sistema de archivos de
caja es el sistema colonial que usaron
para administrar y hacer funcionar lagos
en un momento determinado y cuando miré
la estructura de la caja en sí sentí que
en realidad podría ser una estructura
arquitectónica que también habla de los
entresijos e intrigas de la burocracia
en Lagos durante esa época de la era
colonial también está relacionado con la
bienal de lagos y la casa de la
independencia habla de nuestra historia
pasada con los colonialistas
les dejamos con imágenes de la
exposición Gracias por acompañarnos la
actualidad internacional sigue en
Francia
[Música]